GO AND CAMPAIGN IN-
S FROM ALASKD YE FROM HAWA WOUL
CAMPAIGNACH OTHER.OR
PARTISAN PTT WEIM
ON CHAI
CHEY AND KINZINGER BECAUSE
THE
INVESTIGATION INTO JUAEYCCUSED
CHENEY O IN AR.  TWE YT
SCN IS JUST PLAIN WRG,'T FALSERE
NON-RIGIDLY PARTISAN PERSON
DURINGPERIOD.
>>G THIS PERIOD,.
BUT IT CAN BUNCOMFORTABL
ITUNCOMFORTABLE WHEN YOUG  ALI
LF
PART S BECAUSE THE SAYING.
O BEOMFORTABLE
ENOUGH IN WHO YOESENT AND WHHER
REPRESENTATIF
RTM  THE PRESENTATIVE FORLA
PEOPLE, AND T CHARGEIOUSLY. W A
WHENNG OR SAYING
THINK ARE ABSOLUTELY WRONG, ANL
R O JUSTHE
TRUTH. HARBE PROTECTIOT AND OVE
AN GIVESY, BUT IS  REALL
SENT YOU ?T REALLY WHAT TH WAN?
I DON'T THINK PELET THIN
IT IS HARDERSIO DO
ALONG TO GET ALONG.
JUST KEE KEEP  WHAT?TH'S W
THINGS ARE TO SAY  TO THE HARD
SOMETHING DONE RATHER AN JUST
ESSAGING FROR
T'ETHING DONE.
CLRJHENGINSH ABOE  COMABLE, BUT
ENS.WE HAVE TO, WOULHAER TO
BE TOGETHER, THINGS
TOGETHER, BUCKUR LEADERSHIMES.
WE'VE NATE, OUR
LEAD SHIM, SCHUMER, HERYG
HE SAID, IF YOT
MITCH IS SPO TNG
WEW.
THEY UNDERSTAND.
TO WORK.
AY, ITD NOSERABLE.
T GOING TO BE IN
MISERABLE SITUATION WH I HAV FRW
HINGIOUSLYU'R FIRE FOR NOTNG
FIES.
NGRNIE SANDERS SAYS HE SUPPORTS
SENATOR SINEMA.
ME S
>> WE'VEALKED AT AND
EVERYTHING.
CHALNGI SAID, CHUCT THING TO
TH- THEY'RE GOIN LIKE
SUPPOR, SHAP FORM WILL MIT
McNN NOT
IT JUST DOESN'T HAPPENNOW, WITTK
I CABE O.
IN CHUCK'S SITUATION, I CAN BE
YI DON'T
N RUNNING NC1982.
NEVERPP>> I'LBE FOR YOUNGDORSM?
>> IF HE'S RUNNI, I'LL ENDORSE
HIM.
>> HAVU TALK
AN A SMALLER A CT T GET INTO TH.
FIRST.OW OUR MAINS GET A BUDGET
WEN THE MI
WE HAD A SECUREDNG, OPOLITICAL K
RUSS AOPE LLIES ANTHMILITARY WAO
WHAT CHALLENGES OU HAVE IF
TAY WITH TRESOLUTION.
WORKING OFF OF BASICALLY E LAR
THEY NEE PRESIDENT BIDEN RIGHT
TRYI T HE'S GOING OM U.S. SUE
COURT.
WONDERING HOW IMRTIT, YOU THINKY
THA OEECESSARILY NEED
CANDIDATOSE  CAROLINWHO NDASAIU.
IT'S AWOULD INK YOU WOULD THINRO
PUT HIS MONEE HIS MOUT
IS.
>> EXACTLY SO.
IT BREAKFAST.
NG
I TONE OF THENAN SEND
YO NOMIN E PRILVEL OF BIPARTISAU
EXPT QUARTERBACK
EN
WHO  FORRD
POSITION.
PRESIDENT, I ASKINU
CK ONEHAFUUT TO
T ONE, THAT
ARE NOT ACAHE LEGISLATIVE AND E
EXUTBRANCH.
RIE COUN
LOSING FAITH IN EIR .
THEY'RE LOOKING
-- . DJUNCT OF
>>EDIES BECAUSE OF THERTISAN
RTAN
S BEENMENTIOD EMELY
--
RE
HEY CAN ALL DOER
AVE THE BACKGROUNDND
EXPERIENCE TO DO IT.
I NAMED IN MYASOVERNOR.
THAY  WHERE YOU AREN AKE
THEM LESS E BOIS LOOK FOR THE R
PRCOURT, THINKILROM SOUTH ROLI
GRASSROOTS IPREDICT TH P
HE CHOOSESK MAJORITY OF S, YOU'
IN HISRYFIRSSENATO
>> SO I NOTICE THAVEN'
CRITICIZED PNT BIDEN'S
HA TWOPOHE
SERIOUSLY IDSO ORE POINT.
>> T ATTACKED ITI THINTO
CRITICALLYND TT
COURT TT,R ITS  S
IT'S 110T
ST.E PICTUR
LOT O
E AI
ROF E  AND SI WA T
CANDIDATE, AN EXCEPTIONAL , I WN
N. THINK BASALRT
MAKEUP OF
OUR
IT'S TIME FOR THIS
PICTURE, THIS IS THST BOTH OF
FORCES THATRE
AN WGEDIFFUL
INCENTIVE STRUCTURE IN
LEH >> AREIT
INK ARE OUE  THAT BASICALL IT'S
ANITHER/TION. YOU CAN'T GET AS
'RG .
IF YOU CAN'T COME TO -IF
OU THEVIOLENCE ASTAUTHORIO
WE'RE GOING E THIS AN
EITHER/OPROPOS
GEE E NO
THAT COUO SOMEBODY ON THE OTHERD